le négociateur européen michel barnier
qui salue les photographes
après une journée mouvementée 24 heures
difficiles a résumé sur le visage fermé
du négociateur britannique david frost
la présidente de la commission
européenne our souls à van der leyen
s'est entretenu une nouvelle fois par
téléphone avec le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson
la preuve existe plus que jamais en
suspens en août avec boris johnson nous
avons fait le point sur les négociations
les conditions d'un accord ne sont pas
réunies en raison des divergences qui
subsistent sur des questions
essentielles nous avons demandé à nos
négociateurs en chef de préparer une vue
d'ensemble des différences restantes qui
seront discutés en personne dans les
prochains jours selon londres je cite il
y a toutes les chances pour que les
négociations post break site échoue
boris johnson est d'ailleurs attendu
dans les prochains jours à bruxelles
tension palpable et plusieurs grands
acteurs concernés dans ce dossier ce
lundi une vidéo conférence a réuni
emmanuel macron la chancelière allemande
angela merkel et les chefs de la
commission européenne
ursula von der leyen et du conseil
européen charles michel les ministres
des affaires étrangères de l'ue eux ont
également fait le déplacement dans la
capitale belge
à trois semaines de la fin d'une période
de transition
depuis des mois les discussions entre
londres et bruxelles achoppent sur trois
thèmes la pêche la concurrence équitable
et le mécanisme de règlement des
conflits
la date limite est fixée au 31 décembre
londres qui refuse depuis des mois toute
prolongation
nous sommes prêts à négocier tant qu'il
reste du temps disponible
si nous pensons qu'un accord reste
possible ce lundi boris johnson et son
gouvernement ont écarté l'idée de
négocier encore en 2021
le délai est court d'autant que ce futur
accord de libre échange devra être
ratifié par les parlements britanniques
et européens avant d'entrer en vigueur
le 1er janvier
au royaume uni les députés discutent
d'ailleurs toujours sur les contours des
engagements du breakbeat et la situation
de l'irlande du nord à bruxelles
le scepticisme est de rigueur l'union
européenne est prête à faire un pas
supplémentaire pour décrocher un accord
juste durable et équilibrée c'est au
royaume uni de choisir entre ce
dénouement positif ou un odile si le
royaume uni prend la responsabilité d'un
échec des négociations
ce sera l'unique pays européens sans
accord commercial
ces dernières semaines le négociateur
anglais david frost a insisté sur le
respect de la souveraineté britannique
dans ses négociations avec comme
principal litige l'accès notamment des
pêcheurs européens aux zones britannique
sujet sensible pour la france
à noter qu'en cas de nos deals londres
et bruxelles devront se soumettre dès le
1er janvier 2021 aux règles de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce